Bravo's thicker than water is back
Brooklyn tankard is debuting a whole new
look in season three she's lost more
than 30 pounds a new coca-cola figures
they say after I lost the round wha and
in addition to that I was having a lot
of back pain because my boobs were like
a5z so I had a breast reduction and my
boobs are so big I also had liposuction
so I had two extra baby fat taken out of
my waistline like thank you Jesus that
was of those what handle timing and I
even took a little bit just a little bit
and put it in my hips it's a good where
that that SpongeBob SquarePants
situation I'm still working out as well
so and keeping the healthy lifestyles
and one of the best decisions I've ever
made with the 27 year old reality star
over the phone back in the day when I
was about 200 pounds you know and I was
wearing that way like it was way at the
time and but you can tell me anything
honey
I was just evil it wasn't about needing
to feel like I'm worthy like oh man I
need to feel this way to look worthy to
get my work because that's not what my
value comes from for me I like certain
factions and I like wearing certain
things nothing has changed